Scotland home of the brave
home to of haggis neeps and tatties and
the deep-fried Mars bar
but in Inverness there's a restaurant on
a mission to bring sophisticated French
cooking to my fellow countrymen okay you
send me Cooper start all right now
please it's a vision of French head chef
the week l'affaire who's trained in some
of the best kitchens in France I went to
work for the president in France mr.
Schirach when we are like mr. Bush is
coming our Japanese president is coming
is to do like big function service one
seabass one day level 14 go then I moved
to rock with the pasta water and
Napoleon and there are three Michelin
stars I can't wait to meet a young chef
with such an impressive pedigree hello
they're able to ravish me too much okay
listen team yeah to help realize his
dream loic's hand-picked an impeccably
trained Brigade sous-chef Jeffrey has
worked in Russians with both one and two
mission stars
did you work with Louie in France not
know
I actually miss here it's very good
opportunity to do some of the finishing
stuff
Regis also has a Michelin star studded
background sighs how long have you been
cooking eight years in France and in a
different country you know and so does
the junior of the team Nicola and Nicola
we're bouncing fans are you from with
Brittany not looking football team now
but now you support sells Eagle Rangers
FC not that's it on my field hey you in
you're in Inverness forgot to say you've
got a sport a property and Cheryl's not
letting the side down either his
previous jobs were at Michelin star
level as well Jeff do you have a
Scottish girlfriend yes I French exam
it's a good bike 1,400 miles from the
French Riviera Louie has created a mini
French stronghold in Inverness and no
one's got it in the kitchen
no no Scottish no Scottish I was some
but not anymore
did you sack them no no no no first time
when I came in the kitchen I switch off
the microwave put it in the car park and
pretty laughter I was by myself
I got a message yeah because they were
using microwave all the time
folder for stock deep frying everything
even phoned on potatoes so I had to
build a new tube catch is good loic's
determined that these dream team is
gonna get him his very young englishmen
style pin like Roman Abramovich when he
wanted to get the Premiership title you
went round I got the best manager best
football players and then brought them
all over the Chelsea yeah fantastic
all family Papa's good yeah yeah